Timothy Geitner talks about dealing with
the 2007-2008 financial crisis as
president of the Federal Reserve Bank of
New York and later as President Obama's
Treasury secretary this is about an hour
so I have a pretty simple question to
start why did you write your book Andrew
Sullivan said in the New York Times that
as much as you hate to explain you very
much want to be understood is that true
it was um
okay why did I write the book good
question I never thought I would because
you know I have a hard time sitting
still and it takes a fair amount of
patience to do it but I wanted to give
people a sense of what it was like to
have a chance to look at these choices
we faced through our eyes because they
were pretty bad choices and I think it's
still really hard for people understand
why this was necessary why it was
sensible why was betting the
alternatives and I thought that was
worth worth a shot
and I wanted to give our successors
because you know we're gonna face
financial crises in the future and
they're devastating I want to give our
successors a better framework for making
these choices and a better understanding
of the mix of things we did what worked
what didn't work so that when they faced
this kind of mess in the future they can
they can make better choices and and do
a better job of limiting that damage
those are my those are my motivations so
your central argument I think is that in
a time of financial crisis governments
need to appear to reward the very
institutions that are failing in order
to save the rest of us from the effects
of the crisis and you write in these
severe cases government needs to lean in
against the forces of gloom borrowing
more spending more in exposing taxpayers
to more short-term risk even if it looks
profligate even if it seems to reward
incompetence and banality even if it
fuels perceptions of an out-of-control
money spewing bailout crazy big
government so talk about that well said
thank you I like to plagiarize well you
know when I try to explain is that
financial panics the really severe type
of panic there they happen very rarely
and to protect fuel from the
consequences of the crash the mass
unemployment that Falls panics you have
to do the deeply counterintuitive thing
they're kind of the opposite of what
normally makes sense in response to a
typical financial crisis so again in a
typical recession or a typical case of a
financial institution failing you know
you should basically let the fire burn
let the losses happen you can do that
with relative confidence that it's not
going to spread to the responsible and
the strong you can do with with less
risk of contagion and the benefit of
acting that way is that you hopefully
get incentives better and maybe maybe in
the future at the margin you reduce the
risk that that that behavior that caused
the failure is looked at as attractive
so there's a pretty good moral hazard
argument in the typical crisis for doing
those things but in a panic you got to
do the opposite because if you let the
fire burn too hot you let the run gain
momentum then it'll overwhelm your
defenses
it'll imperil the weak if the strong not
just the weak and you risk mass
unemployment and it's not a hypothetical
risk I mean you know if you just look at
the centuries of financial crises look
at the 50 years of crises before the
Great Depression look at the Great
Depression or look at the last eight
emerging market financial crises of the
90s and you can see what happens when
governments stand back in the face of
runs and panics in the hope they burn
themselves out or out of some aversion
to political risk or aversion to looking
like the rewarding arsonists and when
they let the thing burn in that context
it's like devastating and it's not it's
not important that it's devastating to
investors or shareholders of banks or
managers of banks what's important is
it's devastating to the innocent victims
so again again just remember the Great
Depression you know of course we had no
memory of that most American in a memory
of that but you know unemployment went
to 25% and the economy fell by 25% and
then we had a decade of soup lines and
shanty towns across the country really
around the world and and this in this
crisis
in the fall of a weight the size of the
financial shock at that stage in the
crisis was five times greater then what
happened at the beginning of the Great
Depression so the risks were grave and
severe and and potentially catastrophic
and to protect people from the
consequence or to do as much as we could
to protect the concerts you had to use
overwhelming force to keep the lights on
the financial system even though it
looked deeply unfair even though it
seemed counterintuitive even though it
had moral hazard risk even though it
required taking a lot of financial risk
but if you we hadn't done that then we
were we faced the certainty of
dramatically worse economic outcomes
even than the terrible ones that we
experienced so that that's the that's
the basic thesis of the book and and you
know it's not a it's not an easy thing
to make compelling to people I think
except that if you remember back when it
was like in October of o8 when a bunch
of people for for the right reasons
mostly had let the fire burn to hot it
was devastating it was just devastating
and it was only because we were able
because we're the United States we were
able to put overwhelming force behind
the system and into the economy that we
contain the damage so even the pretty
severe levels that we faced and we're
still living with those scars how do you
find that line between when you should
let the fire burn and when you need to
do the opposite and step in with
overwhelming force and how do you expect
the market to know where that line is
excellent question I think it's really
it's it's the it's the best question
because you know there's this terrible
fog of diagnosis at the beginning
because you can't be sure how vulnerable
you are to the thing tipping over into
panic you can't be sure and in our
crisis although it followed a long boom
and we had many of the preconditions for
pretty severe crisis and they were
observable vulnerabilities you know this
thing basically started in July of oh
seven and it was a sort of a slow burn
for a year mostly limited to the
periphery of the financials
proofread I'm gonna Bear Stearns and
invest we weren't really the periphery
but it wasn't it wasn't really
threatening the core the financial
system and the effects in the economy up
to that point we were pretty modest so
it's pretty hard to judge so what in the
book I try to explain how users think
through the choices you you the right
response initially is to is to let the
fire burn and let it do what it has to
do is tick wishes to consume the weak
weakest institutions that's the rational
response but you just got to be careful
that doesn't get away from you it
doesn't get so much momentum that it
becomes much harder to arrest in that
context and that's just a hard line to
line strike but it but if you don't if
you step in too quickly and protect
every institution because you're too
worried about the panic you'll make a
different kind of error an error error
that might raise the risk of financial
crisis you know bigger crises in the
future so those are hard balance to
strike in in the United States because
we didn't come into this crisis with
enough authority we were late to
escalate you know had to had to let the
terror shock Congress into acting before
we had a smaller set of tools to do
enough to get a get it to get our arms
around a little you know slow the pace
of the run we were just late escalate
because of that that limitation of
authority so a lot of people are mad and
they're still probably going to be mad
after reading your book I thought Jon
Stewart put it pretty memorably he said
this is like an optical illusion one
person looks at it you see a pretty girl
and then you flip it and the other
person looks at it and sees you can
watch it for yourself I can't use Jon
Stewart's language anyway but do you
think you can ever succeed in erasing
the perception by a large chunk of the
population that this was all wrong and
all unfair I don't I mean it's a it's
completely understandable anger and rage
still because the scars of the crisis it
was just so brutal in the damage and
we're still living with this car that
I'm unemployment is still alarmingly
high you've had you know catastrophic
damage to people's savings and sense of
security you know we ought we went into
the crisis pretty high rates of poverty
much worse today people's perception of
inequality and
the opportunity substantially worsened
by the crisis and how could you expect
people understand why it was necessary
or just to protect the institutions that
were the center of of the crisis who
then turned around and paid themselves
pretty generous bonuses for a long time
how could you expect to understand that
I don't think it's understandable but I
can I tell you with complete confidence
and again it's not a hypothetical
theoretical thing that the alternative
of letting the thing collapse and trying
to protect people after that from the
damage would have been deeply
irresponsible and I think immoral to do
because of the cost of damage to
people's livelihood would have been much
much much worse than we faced and again
if you if you hard too hard too hard to
make that compelling to because again
this country had not experienced
anything like this anything like a
classic panic since the Great Depression
and really no memory of the like the
series of great depressions we had
following the panics of the.you know the
financial crises of the you know
previous 50 years before that so hard
thing to expect you to understand and I
don't think that's achievable but it's
still important not not that people will
agree but imports still important I
think for those of us were there trying
to sort through these bad options to try
to give you a better feel for why we did
what we did while we made those choices
because it's it's that's worth doing
even if I think and I have low
expectations for for whether you can
make it seem acceptable understandable
so your first by the way I didn't I
don't remember I think Johnson was more
vivid than you said but I don't think I
don't think this was pretty I don't
think you look at this and say oh it was
it was it was this cool elegant thing it
was a messy horrible tragic thing it
just would have been dramatically worse
if we had done what most people argued
we should do so your first real public
performances Treasury Secretary was in
early February 2009 those were dark days
and the country was looking to you and
you're right it's fair to say the speech
did not go well i swayed back and forth
like an unhappy passenger on an unsteady
ship I tried to sound forceful but I
just sounded like someone trying to
sound forceful you said that Larry
Summers actually came to your office and
said I can't tell you what to do but I
wouldn't give a speech like this
seriously as a life question how do you
hang in there through that especially
when you when you don't get to go home
and curl up in a ball on your bed Barney
Barney Frank said that when I appeared
in public was like it was at my bar
mitzva
um well you know I made this this
decision which I think was the right
decision even with the even in
retrospect to go out and lay out this
framework for the next stage of our
strategy at a pretty early time when we
didn't have all the details yet about
how we were actually gonna do it because
I thought the vacuum was pretty damaging
at that point people were filling the
vacuum with all sorts of ideas and
expectations for what we should do which
we weren't gonna do and I needed to suck
the hope out of the air about some of
the stuff you wanted us to do and I
needed to have a device to try to force
a little bit of end to the debates we
were having internally about what to do
because if you know you you could sit
there and debate these things forever
because it all it's all sucks and you if
you just let the if you let people argue
about it forever
you'll never decide anything so I made a
choice to go early with the general
framework no details not enough details
and and there were a lot of things in
that frame we were a pretty scary
framework because the stress tests the
total my book the device we use to
recapitalize the banking system was
something people never heard of before
there's no precedent for it
and it was a little alarming because
most people were still living with the
hope that we were going to have the
government come in and go buy from these
banks a bunch of these bad assets
inflated prices as a way to keep the
bank's alive they wanted us to do I know
this sounds inexplicable because most
people thought what we do is way too
generous but the what people wanted us
to do then even internally was to do
something much more generous to the bank
share along the banks and we did and we
I needed it to suck the hope out of the
air for that so it was and yeah it was I
said oh it's a terrible speech and I
wasn't great at doing that but we had a
bigger problem too which is that I made
this choice to go out early pretty
general with a framework that a lot of
uncertainty in it and that was a very it
made the made the everything a little
more scary even than it was then but we
did what I said we would do everything I
said we would do we did
not all of it had to say has much
traction or power as we hoped but the
overall effect of that strategy was much
more effective than even we thought all
the time because the economy when I when
we started was shrinking an annual rate
of about eight percent we were losing
three quarter million jobs a month and
within six months the economy was
growing at 3% incredibly rapid
turnaround for a world economy was the
edge of collapse and that was because of
the force and the strength of what
fiscal stimulus delivered what the Fed's
policy delivered and the scale of that
strategy that the the sort of the
content of the strategy that I first
laid out in that not not well-received
speech so let's retrace some of the
steps that led to that moment you are a
career public servant but you somewhat
accidentally developed a specialty in
financial crises from Mexico to Asia I
love this line Mervyn King the former
governor the Bank of England said
whenever there was a crisis tim was
there but you didn't cause the crisis
the crisis caused you I think he
probably thought I caused some of them
but he was being he was being gracious
yeah I grew up overseas mostly and I
decided having had that experience
living in India and Thailand studying in
China that I wanted you know you get to
watch your country from a different
vantage point and see the enormous
effect we can have in the world mostly
for good but not always for good and I
wanted to decide that I wanted to lis
spend part of my life trying to affect
those decisions and so I went to the
Treasury pretty early in life as a civil
servant 1988 I was 27 I think 28 and and
I never thought I would do it for for
long but I had this really rewarding
experience of working with people that
were they were really excellent
completely ethical there was no net
nobody had this sort of naive existence
where politics rarely got in the way
or in a negative way interfered with the
choices about policy and and as you said
I had this experience of watching and
being there and being part of or helping
or observing a bunch of countries deal
with pretty devastating financial crises
very valuable experience I had no idea
how valuable but very valuable
experience because I lived in Japan
worked in Japan just as their economy
was collapsing watched watched how they
embraced a strategy of kind of mostly
drift sideways drift for a long time
didn't do much to clean up the financial
system looked at the cost of that and of
course watched the emerging economies
blow themselves up and in rapid
succession that was a very good
experience to go through and it you know
taught me a lot about how fragile these
systems are how damaging that can be
when they fall apart it gave me a good
lesson in the typical mistakes
governments make over and over again it
was a great lesson in the in the
importance of overwhelming force it was
a we fought debated each of those times
all these classic moral hazard debates
the worst sore president crises it was a
good it was a good um it was a good
education and humility in crises so your
the night before your first day of work
as president of the New York Federal
Reserve what happened well I was they
asked me to go to come run the New York
Fed in the fall of 2003 and my kids were
in school in Washington then and I was
gonna move them in the school year so I
went and rented apartment New York and
my first my first night in New York I
went to buy some stuff for breakfast and
I bought a six-pack of beer and I was
carted
that was hey that was a somewhat awkward
beginning yeah so let's talk a little
bit about your time as president of the
New York Fed er chapter in your book is
called leaning against the wind and you
talk about your growing fears about some
things about what came to be known as
the shadow banking system all the stuff
going outside on outside of the
regulated banking system and your work
to clean up the derivatives market your
critics aren't having it after the
release of the Federal Reserve's
transcripts from its 2008 policy
meetings The Wall Street Journal branded
you as one of its losers and part
because you've said in early 2008 in the
financial markets I think it's true that
there are some sign that the process of
repairs is starting and Bear Sterns Bear
Stearns collapse just a few weeks later
so talk talk about this were you really
leaning against the wind well I try to
talk very honestly openly about the
stuff we missed and the stuff we tried
why it failed why it was so inadequate
and I described in you know I try to do
a fair job of going through this of
laying out the things that I described
that we thought were reassuring about
our system even going into the crisis
and things that were troubling but let's
just do the basic let's just do the
basic contours or our system at that
point so to give you some feel for it
was like to see it then you know what
happened in our system is over the
decades that followed the Great
Depression as the memory of the panic
faded our financial system completely
outgrew the safeguards we put in place
around banks after the Great Depression
so then that case we'd have major panic
we put in place a bit of constraints on
banks deposit insurance and the Fed the
Fed had a sort of protection safety net
provided as part of the Leonard's last
resort function and over time we evolved
in the United States and that long boom
they call it the quiet they call it the
quiet period of decades this set of
other institutions that were not
constrained in terms of capital or
leverage had no access to Deposit
Insurance for the safety net for the
system and we evolved over time in in
Fannie and Freddie as you've written
about eloquently
the investment banks some big insurance
companies
G capital and a whole universe of
non-bank financial institutions this
whole complicated complicated world of
essentially banks more risky than banks
because they were not constrained in
terms of leverage and more risky than
banks because they have no access to
deposit insurance protection against
runs and the in our system the feds
reach was limited to a part of the
banking system but the banking system
was only about 40% of the financial
system and credit and that other 60% was
much more risky very vulnerable to runs
and when I get when I get to the New
York Fed in the in that fall of three I
think what worried me most was that big
mismatch between where there was risk
where there were constraints where there
was somebody nominally in charge and the
scope of the firefighting Authority that
even we had because you know that you
know when when things fell apart which
they might do you know people generally
say where's the Fed what are you gonna
do about it they come ask us for money
and you know we had pretty limited tools
at that point so that told me a lot and
I and I wrote a fair amount about what
in the face of that I tried to do we try
to do to lean against the forces of
optimism that were causing this big boom
and leverage and risk but as I write
those those efforts were of course very
weak against the force of the boom
inadequate late insufficient not because
it wasn't lot to worry about but because
we had no direct authority over
Institute where most of the risk was and
even where we had Authority like over
bands you know we didn't we didn't think
about forcing him to hold capital
against the risk of a Great Depression
you know because people thought great
depressions can't happen in the United
States
no just see they seemed inconceivable
now we we know we took those lessons and
tried to read the rules of the game of
the fan system because of the because of
those the costly lessons in that context
and that those lessons I think informed
what are very powerful promising
designer reforms that you know we're now
putting into place but but yeah we
missed a lot and didn't do enough in
advance so bring us back to the fall of
2008 and try to explain the sheer amount
of fear there was there's a great story
in the book about a conversation you had
with Lloyd Blankfein around then well um
you know sort of Gathering Storm or you
know burning fire getting a lot momentum
and by the fall of 2008 the system
really was at the edge of collapse and
it was happening around the world and
with what people called Lehman weekend
that weekend we brought the major
institutions together at the New York
Fed to try to figure out a way to the
damage and avert default by the biggest
institutions at that at that weekend
Lehman and Merrill Lynch and AIG were
we're all all basically at collapse and
if they collapsed the system was gonna
gonna was gonna fail and although we
were able to find us a solution to
Merrill Lynch and aji we had without a
willing buyer for Berlin we had no good
option so in the wheat weeks I write in
the weeks and the weeks after that when
the system was basically breaking down
there was a classic run across the
system I got a phone call one morning
from from you know this very prominent
banker and and maybe 6:30 I was at my
desk and I called him back right after
and said you know you have to get that
out of your voice don't talk to anybody
else in your firm we're outside because
if they hear you
you know it'll it'll be it'll be
terrible and
I say you know you can replace it with
anger or whatever you want but you can't
let people hear you either but but as I
explained in my book if you were if you
were if you were aware then you were
scared to death and it was the people
who did weren't scared you had to worry
about the most the people who were
scared were the more smart in the
contour competent was there any who
actually wasn't scared yeah I mean
remember what after Lehman that morning
after Lehman the Wall Street Journal
doctoral page the New York Times
editorial page thought it was terrific
they said thank goodness they didn't
step in and find a solution of revolt
they thought it was a gonna be a just
virtuous excellent imposition of pain
against the on the deserving ever they'd
have no effect on the rest of us that
was the dominant view of the time so
yeah there are a lot of people a lot of
people who who thought going into the
weekend you know all of Washington was
caught in this fever of saying that it
had been too many too much rescuing
going on no more rescues now then they
got scared to death and and they you
know gave the gave President Bush and
Hank Paulson the authority that we
needed in the end to put out the fire
but yeah there were huge number of
people still who I had no from no sense
for how perilous it was that you argue
there was no desire to moral hazard at
work and the decision not to save Lehman
it was clearly what you could do it's a
important thing to just I know it seems
inexplicable but the in finance it's not
like national security you know we don't
give the president eyes this standing
authority to put out financial fires we
don't do it because of moral hazard
concerns we think if you do that then
investors will take too much risk
because they'll they'll live with the
expectation that the government come in
to protect them so this this our
president even the United States came in
with no authority except to declare a
bank holiday or close the equity markets
not not things that are helpful in a
panic and and so the tragic failure in
some sense of the country going into
this moong the many failures was we
didn't have the tools to contain the
damage early enough ultimately we were
able to do it but not not not not not
until a lot of damage was baked into the
outcomes so that and the Fed also by
design limited tools I write in my book
about how when I went to the New York
Fed initially in 2003 they they showed
me this book they called the Doomsday
book and I thought oh this would be cool
and it was terrifying because it was
three inches thick but did it which I
did
carefully it was a pretty limp weak set
of things because again by design people
who created the authority for the Fed
didn't want the Fed to step in and
preemptively
bailout or rescue and even when they
gave us that authority was very limited
and aren't we weren't allowed to take
that much risk the statute says that
even those emergency powers you can only
lend if the president york that could be
secured to his or her satisfaction and
what so does that mean that means you
have to be able to say we're lending not
against air but we're letting against
something that we might have the
capacity of using deploying to losses
very limited on a risk no ability
guarantee no be able to put capital into
institutions so for that reason without
a willing buyer in the lehman case had
had no good options and i also write in
the book about how you know i was very
confident we had a willing buyer but we
needed to do what we did in Bear Stearns
which is we had the Fed take some of the
risk to make that happen that I'm very
confident we would have done that and it
and that Hank and Ben would have
supported that now we would have people
would have been unhappy with us for
doing it because because again just to
go back to the beginning it seemed
counterintuitive and paradoxical and
unfair that would be appropriate or
necessary but again just look at the
damage that happened in the wake of that
default
so I think it's David Arad who called
your relationship with President Obama a
bromance you did try to talk him out of
choosing you as Treasury secretary but
you ended up being the longest-serving
member of his legal team so talk a
little bit about that relationship well
I didn't know him and we met in I got
this call asked me to come see him in
New York in October before the election
and we talked with real nice talk and we
had a little bit common background in
the sense we both lived in Southeast
Asia when we were kids or we were
younger and our parents were served in
the same profession his mother and my
father but I had we didn't know him and
he said to me after we talked he said
you know my have to actually come to
Washington and I said that and do that
and I had a bunch of good reasons for
that I think that helps a little bit
because he knew that I wasn't eager to
come do this and tried to talk him out
of it but then we you know but we had to
spend a lot of time together and we had
to we had we went through a lot of ugly
messy horrible decisions together and
and you know I just have the most you
know the amazing admiration for him
because he's it for me at least all that
you wanted much more than you could have
hoped for in a president because he all
he cared about was trying to figure what
was the right thing to do what was gonna
be the most effective thing in avoiding
the most you know getting a coming
growing as quickly as quickly as
possible he wasn't gonna let the
short-term political cost of that
interfere with what was right he was
both very supportive of the the path we
agreed I stuck with it but he also was
very hard on us very hard on me in in
the sense of subjecting my
recommendations to pretty tough internal
debate deliberation it was never
paralyzed by that but he did the right
thing which is to make sure that he
wasn't
he wasn't who's gonna look at all
options before he embraced what I laid
out I thought he was just a great
decision-maker very brave heart very
creative at that at that moment where
where it mattered so much I mean I'll
tell you one small story just we had the
first phone call we had in the
transition with the but with the Vice
president-elect and the chief of staff
and maybe a couple other people it was a
call to talk about his economic agenda
in the first term and I began and said
well mr. president-elect
you're gonna prevent a second Great
Depression that's that's what your
economic team is gonna be and he was he
snapped at me on the phone and he said
well I just want you know that's not
enough for me I'm not gonna be defined
by what I'm what I prevented and and I I
admired the fact that he was willing to
understand that economic and fair was
central nothing was possible without
without hurting the the worst crisis but
he was focused on how he was gonna
figure out a way to create a covert
governing coalition to do make some
progress against all the many other
challenges we face as a country and I I
admired that ambition and his epic
capacity to look through the immediate
imperative and devote the capital you
needed imperative but still look beyond
it to these other challenges we face as
a country so you have some great mottos
that seem to be more broadly applicable
than in a financial crisis but mottos
for life plan beats no plan B fluff not
just against stuff and talk a little bit
about how these affected you during the
debate inside the administration in
early 2009 when a number of people were
arguing for nationalizing the banks and
you stood pretty much alone against that
well it wasn't really a debate about
whether we should nationalize are not
nationalized because it was possible
that if that if banks were unable to
raise an
capital to give themselves the resources
to survive great like losses then we
were going to put a lot more capital in
and people would call that
nationalization and that that might have
been unavoidable and desirable in that
context but I think the the the what I
learned early in life about how you make
decisions context is that you have to
surround yourself with people who are
who are not just reasonably smart and
ethical and people you can trust
with the diversity of backgrounds
experience who have enough you have
capacity for conviction are willing to
say what therefore are willing to take
the risk and saying well we how about
this because mostly what you find in
these cases is that people want to
debate the problem say it's not a
problem
hope it'll go away or just describe the
challenges and you you can't have any
effect on the choices you have to make
if all you can do is describe your
concern the concern is important it's
very valuable but it doesn't get you to
a choice so what I try to do always just
was just to to you know have the table
around the table group of people who
were prepared to go relentlessly through
all the available choices and try to
sort through the best of the bad ones
and try to figure out which risks were
the better risk to take what the cost of
the mistakes would be could you correct
those mistakes because you're gonna make
mistakes and to help people think
through those kind of choices and that
that's the that's the discipline I tried
to bring to these choices in a crisis
and so you know you know I always used
plan meets no plan it's just a good a
good short version of trying to convince
people that you know they had to decide
what they were for not just we were
against and what we with the president
did which is very good is again trying
to let there be enough competition for
diagnosis and idea is that he could have
a better feel for what was the best
among those bad choices and I write in
the book about how what happened over
time as we work through
those choices is that the alternatives
most of them couldn't survive 30 minutes
of debate because they were that well
intentioned but they had you know just
bad risk where they were much too risky
relatives a returner they deep beyond
realistic or we know authority to do
them or you know they assumed the
unicorns would exist or something like
that and and you but you have to work
through those things it's really sucked
the home where there's no hope and
expose people to their to their
infirmities so talk a little bit about
the toll this took on your life and on
your family what was it like to have the
daily show pay a visit to your house
Tillie show they had a lot of fun with
me I think the president said in the
Oval Office we just have these morning
meetings on the economy really terrible
and he remember him coming the morning
and saying seriously it's like the
second time you're on started I left
seven alive you know
it was not a big it was not very good
but the you know I love my work and I
had great people around me and a very
supportive president and it wasn't you
know it's not so fun for me sometimes
but this is very hard in your families
it's nothing like you know families that
people serve in the military or in in
the fire department or first responders
but it's it's still hard because you
know you they have no privacy and they
never see you and when you're around
you're not there when you're president
you're not really present so it's not
very fun for them so there were these
repeated misperceptions of you both
before you became Treasury secretary and
during the time that you you served Rahm
Emmanuel's wife told you that you must
be looking forward to your returning to
your nice career at goldman sachs and
there's a great interview and a great
anecdote in the book about your meeting
with Barbara Streisand so tell us about
that and about why why you think it is
you say that people never really got to
know you why that is well I'm you know
we were doing stuff that was deeply
unpopular again
by on its face looked like it was
designed to reward the arsonists and you
know people wrote about me early on and
this this perception just became
conventional wisdom and hardened very
quickly that I that I'd spend my life at
Coleman sacks I write I read I write
about this being a hearing in the hill
and this member of the Congressional
Oversight Panel said to me he began a
question to me by saying well mr.
Geithner of course you're a banker I
said no actually not a banker
well you were in banking I said no so we
were investment in Investment Banking I
said no never Investment Banking but but
that perception
partly because that initial description
of my past and probably because of the
of what we were doing just hardened
became overwhelmingly accepted wisdom
and you know the way the world works is
one of those perceptions matter a lot
and when those perceptions hardened
they're they're very hard very hard to
break so another policy question some of
the fiercest criticism of you during
your tenure and of your book has come
about the help that was offered for
homeowners in one critic wrote at every
turn on housing the evidence points to
Tim Geithner preferring what upper
option put the least pressure on banks
rather than actually helping ordinary
people I know that's a common perception
but it's just a deeply confused
perception and it rests on a on a just a
deeply unrealistic sense of of what what
our choices were what our options were I
mean we had a Democratic president that
really at the peak of his political
power with Democratic majorities in both
houses I think some of the best housing
talent in the country working for him a
lot of progressive economists all the
right incentives understanding housing
was terrible
and it was getting worse still and he
put enormous pressure on all of us to
try to figure out how we could do more
to make it more likely people could
wouldn't lose their homes and you know
but it was a terrible recession millions
of people lost their jobs and the scale
of those problems were 11 million
Americans underwater they get it back we
at the peak was 700 billion dollars and
the scale of those challenges were just
vast relative to the resources authority
we had and we were unable to relax those
constraints than our Authority unable to
get more authority from Congress unable
to get more resources in a material
scale and and we were definitely slower
and less creative than I think we would
have liked and I think we ultimately
were in using the authority we had we
did ultimately help means that people
keep stay in their homes and refinance
and we did put a floor under house
prices and lay the conditions for
recovery but ultimately ultimately what
it took was when people started to get
jobs again that was when you started to
see the pain start to EV a little bit
things trying to get better because
again once you had an income again you
were gonna be more like a be able to
stay current on your mortgage and the
scale of that stuff just wasn't just
wasn't large enough but again it wasn't
because we didn't know it was terrible
it had nothing to do with nothing to do
with helping the banks I mean people are
just it's just upside down I mean if if
we had been able to get 700 billion
others from the Congress and use it to
help people stay current in their
mortgages or reduce their mortgage
balance that would have been terrific
for the banks thanks for the love that
it would have just taken a whole bunch
of losses off their table so the and you
know in some sense that what the stress
test was designed to do the stress test
remember the the the core of it was to
say we're gonna say these are the losses
you banks would face foreclosures
defaults by businesses if it was a Great
Depression
so the purpose of the stresses was to
point out and make it possible for banks
to withstand those losses to illustrate
that we force them have enough capital
they could withstand those losses so
their their their their criticism of the
program is correct in the sense that
they were inadequate but it's deeply
confused in terms of what the options
were and what our motivations were it is
one thing that confused me a little bit
because you do right at the end of the
book I wish we had expanded our housing
programs earlier to relieve more pain
for homeowners but I actually think your
book is a quite compelling defense of
what you did do and why so is it really
true that you would that you would do
things differently that you would do
more well let's let's separate these two
things actually I gonna try to be very
open with this in the in the book within
the scope of the authority we had we did
pretty persistent innovation evolution
expansion of our programs to try to get
more traction because they were
disappointing in their reach but we
didn't do that you know we were learning
as we were doing it if we had full
knowledge at at year one of what we had
year four and could have done it all
earlier that would been great is that
possible as possible I guess but again
we have some pretty excellent housing
people a lot of knowledge right
incentives president I stays pretty
north pressure on them on us but anyway
that's that's one thing I say so yeah if
we had expanded those things more
quickly and more traction earlier within
the authority that would have been a
great but the big constraint was on I'll
just give you an example
pretty pretty ironic example when when
Paulson got authority to put Fannie and
Freddie into conservatorship authority
to put capital into which was necessary
prevent their collapse Congress did not
give the secretary Treasury any power
over what they did just power to give
them money not power to influence what
they did so I'll give you an example of
what that meant so we we you guys
understand there's a big good
Kannamma case for principal reduction in
financial crises particularly for people
at the risk of losing their homes so we
spent a lot of time looking at the case
for principal reduction we came to the
judgment not as early as I think I
should have that there was a pretty good
case for doing it having Fannie and
Freddie do it so we went into this big
effort with Fannie and Freddie to
convince them to do a targeted program
of pencil reduction that would have
benefited hundreds of thousands of
people we had no authority to force them
to do it we laid out the numbers for
them tried to make the economic case for
doing it they didn't want to do it so
even though they existed because of the
money we were giving them in capital
that came with no authority why was that
wasn't because Democratic Congress did
not want to give a Republican president
authority over controlling their things
so that that constraint on Authority was
very consequential unable to relax it so
you could say it's a failure to of ours
that we were unable to relax the
constraint that's a very different
criticism from saying that we left
unexploited unused Authority we've been
hugely powerful in that context so there
are tons of good questions from the
audience and I'm some fall into
categories but so I'm going to start
with this one what have you learned
about navigating the US political system
during a crisis requiring immediate and
decisive action and the international
political system I don't think I learned
very much about politics I don't
understand the I don't really understand
that place and and it's the kind of a
it's kind of a soul-crushing experience
to go through this there's just so much
hypocrisy and adolescent posturing and
it's it's it's not very funny learn very
much about that in the on the you know
in in politics and internationally or
here in Washington you know the the most
important thing you can do is to try to
figure out what are the interests and
incentives and beliefs and constraints
of the people you're negotiating with
that's important because unless you have
a better feel for those things there's
no way you can have any chance of moving
them or finding where your interests
might might overlap might be coincident
might be complementary so you know you
need to come to these discussions with
at least a willingness to try to
understand what your opponent's or your
critics or your counterparts think about
the world even if it's a very different
view and if you don't agree with that
view you have to understand it because
you still have to figure out a way to
find the capacity for compromise and you
know this country has over time
demonstrated a pretty pretty remarkable
pragmatic capacity for compromise on
reform we just seem to lost our way for
the moment well will rediscover at some
point but it does take that it just
takes effort and a bit of appreciation
for you know for where you can find some
complimentary interests so please
compare the European to the US response
to the financial crisis well ours was
better
I mean they they had a heart they'd a
harder problem in many ways it's why I
think a Federation of 17 countries no
institutions for common strategy but you
know like many Americans thought was
ideal in the fall of a wave for the
first three years of crisis and someone
reckons late I think still think we did
better for us and for the first three
years of the crisis and this is a pretty
helpful illustration of the consequences
of a different strategy they decided
that they wouldn't I think put some fuel
in the fire not just let the fire burn
but they thought the fire was gonna be
just and you know put a bunch of
deserving brutal pain on the more
profligate investors banks governments
and then they they induced a bunch of
additional austerity even by countries
that had plenty of resources very strong
fiscal positions and those two things
caused you know almost great depression
like outcomes and big blow up large
parts of Europe and they and they
flirted over and over again with the
risk of complete collapse of the euro
area and then something in August of
2012 they decided that strategy wasn't
very good strategy and so they reversed
course relaxed the austerity and
basically rhetorically if not in reality
they stacked a bunch of money in the
window
the ECB did to try to calm the fires of
the of the panic and they bought
themselves about a much more room now to
begin to reform and but they're they're
a good they're a good natural experiment
in the cost of the alternative strategy
it's very painful and it's not it's not
the austerity they induced was not just
the fiscal avoidable fiscal austerity
they induced but if you let financial
markets
live with panic like conditions for a
long period of time which they did for
three years it's devastating on the
capacity of businesses to to expand to
borrow to hire people retain people it's
just devastating good national
experiment so if if people like that
alternative you should go live in Spain
so there's a question here do you think
Fannie and Freddie will be reconstructed
and if so how and when and I have to add
on to that just a little note do you
think it's ironic that some of the
institutions that you are accused of
treating so favorably are now suing you
for their favorable treatment and I
don't mean you personally obviously but
included in that Fannie and Freddie and
AIG I do think it's ironic that I mean
it just just so you know the context of
this stuff there are you know this is a
this is a rescue that most people viewed
as as as way too generous to the
arsonists and unjust unfair and and yet
the government is being sued for making
too much money for the taxpayer on the
largest most riskiest things we did in
the case of those three institutions do
I think Fannie Freddie will be reformed
that's where you started yep
yeah at some point I do I mean I think
that it's gonna take a while because
this political system again can't do
can't really do anything now and this is
a complicated thing it's a very risky
reform process because what has you
written about eloquently but produced
the mess in Fannie and Freddie was this
coalition of real estate interests
well-intentioned housing advocates and
and banks pretty powerful coalition a
little bit of left progressives a little
bit of market in that coalition we
called it the housing industrial complex
and they have a pretty strong grip on
the political system and so I always
felt at least when I was there that not
not good to rush this because if you
tried to rush the reform process I know
it doesn't look like you're rushing it
but try to rush the reform process the
risk is you'd strengthen the hand of
that coalition and they try to recreate
a set of conditions that were probably
not not not sensible you know a badly
designed excessively generous subsidy to
housing with a bunch of bad incentives
for the institutions at the core
that so I think it's it's okay if it
takes some time I know it's doesn't seem
ideal it's okay if it takes some time
you know the housing markets got a long
way to go to heal private capital is not
really coming back with alacrity into
that market government's still the only
thing in town economy is not that strong
still so it should be a gradual process
and you want to be you want to run a
legislative process that maximizes the
chance that what that the reforms the
successor regime is dramatically better
than the one you had before and that
that might be might take some time
so this could be a short answer or a
long answer and I'm going to ask the
question on the chance that the answer
is a long one what are your thoughts
about the current controversy around
high-frequency trading well I think it's
a it's a a necessary just desirable
level of attention to a problem that has
no you know no no obvious easy solutions
yet it's going to take a long time to
figure out a better framework but it's
worth it's worth the attention so I'm
for the controversy and the attention
and hopefully it produces some changes
that make those markets you know have a
bit more integrity and a little less
risk of catastrophic damage so in the
book you are you are quite pleased with
with with dodd-frank you you you think
it really did make a difference and go a
long way toward making the financial
system safer but you also write about
the the very thing in this person's
question and somebody would like you to
comment on why the revised rules for the
FDIC guarantee authority and the
limitations on fed authority are
problematic so talk about that in the
context of some of the things that
aren't so great about dodd-frank um well
let me just describe two of the most
important things dodd-frank did they we
did put in place a lot of credit to
Elizabeth Warren a new framework for
consumer protection that is much better
designed more powerful better
accountability and will be better not
perfect but better at preventing
the level of predation peda Tori stuff
and abuse that happened against the risk
of future financial crises we have much
better authority to impose much more
conservative constraints on risk-taking
much more broadly remember before the
crisis to no.7 the ones that existed
applied to about 40% of the financial
system they were too thin
- but now they're much more conservative
and they're applied much more broadly
you know we banks can't through
acquisition any more than 10% the
banking system that's a much more
restricted limit on consolidation
concentration exists anywhere in the
planet we have we force big banks to
hold much more capital for the same
amount of risk any mortgage relative to
a small bank this is a systemic
surcharge and there's better bankruptcy
like authority to dismember large
institutions like Lehman Bear Stearns
AIG that we didn't have in the panic
those are all good things but in the in
the pocket and that's a deeply populist
moment in Washington they took away some
of the firefighting authority that was
so important to protect people from from
the from a much worse recession they
took away the FDS real condition the
FDIC's guarantee authority and I think
less consequentially did a little
tightening up but stuff I recommended
actually on the Fed we said for example
I thought the Fed shouldn't be able to
do firm specific interventions in the
future like AIG or Bear Stearns only
generally available stuff if you want to
do firm specific things that should be
left to the to the government as soon as
it was my view the guarantee authority
thing is very consequential because it
was one of the most effective things
that was done to limit the force of the
panic in the fall of eight and it's the
only way you brake panics I mean sorry
one of the only way she can brake panics
and what happened was Congress although
it wasn't very controversial at the time
Congress got a little caught up in a
belief that in finance the fire stations
what caused fires it's just it's not
true you know it's it just doesn't
happen that way where they got caught up
in this belief that somehow if you if
you limit the tools available to fire
station you make fires less likely
that's also not true but still they got
caught up in that base
you believe so they limited condition
that authority and what that means is is
that you know because politicians are
not are not going to rush to do the
right thing in a panic because it's so
deeply unpopular what it means is that
the Congress will be late like it was
this time they'll be late in the future
when it's severe and that that's gonna
be very costly thing I still think on
balance though if you look at the
reforms although they're messy and
complicated and imperfect these core
reforms around limiting risk are very
powerful and they're very well designed
and they're gonna buy us a a they have
the chance of buying us a long period of
relative stability not not permanent
there's nothing permanent this because
as people become more confident
eventually risk will migrate around
those constraints and you face the risk
again of something more severe but on
balance even with those limitations that
contains in the firestation the the
reforms I think are are are really
pretty good ok so I think we have time
for one last question and this one is
are you still doing your taxes with
TurboTax
no I got a good education though in the
complexity of the tax system and and
generally believe in paying for advice
well thank you all very much